Heather and Terry shooting your book
cover congratulations only ET was behind
the scenes as Heather and Terry Dubrow
shot the cover for their new book dr.
and mrs. guinea pig presents the only
guy you'll ever need it to the best
anti-aging treatments we call ourselves
dr. and mrs. guinea pig because we go
out in the world and we try everything
health wellness and beauty on ourselves
basically we're giving everyone who's
interested in looking their best and
feeling their best all the best beauty
secrets you can find anywhere on the
planet that work and we're telling you
the ones that are very popular that
actually don't work yeah so is it real
or is it snake oil working with a
significant other isn't always easy but
Heather and Terry say it actually brings
them closer together we don't work
together full-time so when we get to do
something like writing our book together
or doing console beauty or a product
line that's a labor of love for us I
think that's the secret a relationship
where two people are very busy find a
way to work together if you can even if
it's just a hobby yeah or something
cooking or exercising or working in many
projects like we do this will keep you
happy this will keep you together and
this will keep you excited and
interesting we make a concerted effort
to be together we make sure that we have
date nights we make sure we schedule sex
sorry mom if you're watching but it's
just the way it goes
we're married for almost like what 20
years and four kids so you know
something happens it's very important
you have to stay connected and one thing
I've discovered recently is based on I
love to FaceTime Heather in the middle
of by the way is annoying she actually
is very annoyed by it instead of calling
her a test me right now want to FaceTime
you don't why cuz I want to see her oh
and there's one more tip my biggest tip
for a very healthy relationship is
separate bathrooms which we don't have
right now but very soon now we're
muddling through yes no pun intended